bene
Allora bene leviamo Antonino via subito
andiamo una cosa omo Un secondo solo per
dire è appassionante la radice di questa
parola Homo che viene da una parola
indoeuropea cioè xam che è misurato
limitato sa tutto ciò che c'è intorno
l'uomo è senza fare tutti i passaggi Chi
li vuole posso mandare la fotocopia del
testo da cui l'ho preso per arrivare a
humus
humilies Ok andiamo avanti
50 miliardi di Specie nella vita che si
sono sviluppate solamente sulla terra
Quindi voi immaginate Dove ci troviamo
ci troviamo davanti in un luogo dove
qualcuno qualcosa non sappiamo Io so
Penso anche ho un'idea Non solo io ha
messo una potenza di sviluppare vita che
non si è che superiore a qualsiasi
aspettativa queste 50 miliardi di specie
tra vegetali e animali hanno avuto una
durata di esistenza di 2 milioni di anni
Ok andiamo avanti mostruoso bellissimo
Vabbè qui riconoscete tutti questi
personaggi Guardate che soggettivi così
Homo habilis homo erectus Eh questo è un
passaggio decisivo Mica male Homo ne
andar talentis Neanderthal va bene
andiamo avanti è solo per farvi vedere
arriva lui
Homo Sapiens Anzi lo chiamano sapiens
così questo è più o meno la durata
andiamo avanti
questo è la cosa che invece voglio con
la quale voglio attirarvi un concetto
unico da mandarvi oggi che è questo che
cosa abbiamo
ricevuto come dote Ecco
da tutta la storia della vita sulla
terra abbiamo detto 50 miliardi di
specie Ma dobbiamo dire che è iniziata
l'esperienza della vita 3 miliardi 600
milioni di anni fa È impressionante ed è
partita con lei con certe alghe o
batteri non si sa che è stato il primo
le alghe o batteri Ma hanno spaccato il
Co l'ossido di carbonio ed è arrivato
l'ossigeno e si è creata man mano
un'atmosfera dove noi avremmo potuto
vivere ma che cosa abbiamo ereditato fin
da quelle alghe fino a tutti gli uomini
non è che il messaggio che ho da darvi
che non so se avrò coraggio di darvelo
in pieno con Tutta energia che vorrei
mettere in questo messaggio e che non
pensiate che l'uomo viene condizionato
quando arriva qua sulla terra capite
e per cui viene traumatizzato
influenzato condizionato ridotto
deviato deformato ammalato reso
patologico e dipendente da quello che
avviene qui No no ragazzi ragazzi
insomma molti sono ragazzi altri un po'
meno
Noi abbiamo ereditato una disposizione
permanente a rimanere in vita e lottare
per rimanere in vita perché quei due
milioni non li avrebbe fatti nessuno
senza aver ricevuto una forza immensa
per rimanerci nella scena quindi che è
prodotta attraverso queste tre cose
disposizioni a monitorare in un modo
implacabile implacabile chi non dovesse
intuire di chi parlo Basta che si
ricordi come si comportano le donne le
donne hanno un'attenzione che non cessa
mai
il maschio l'uomo qualche volta può
mollare distrarsi Ma le donne non
finiscono mai i loro compiti
monitorare e rilevare potenziali minacce
Questa è una disposizione l'altra che
meno conosciuta ma altrettanto
pericoloso è la tendenza ad esaltare
esaltare del loro nel suo valore
qualunque opportunità materiale o in
materiale di salvezza dal pericolo dalla
minacce per spianare la strada e
continuare la nostra esistenza Ok terza
tendenza una sperimentazione dell'uomo
che non ha fine ok
aumenti di attivazione questa parolaccia
rausel vuol dire attivazione
aumento della velocità della sequenza
con meno soste aumento dei consumi è una
parola che oggi è passata di moda non si
sente più ma io raccomando tutti gli
studenti di psicologia tutti quelli che
si occupano di comportamento umano di
ricordarsi che
i problemi vengono sempre preceduti o
annunciati da una qualche deplezione
depressione vuol dire passare dal pieno
a una condizione che non è più piena di
risorse di neurotrasmettitori gli
aspetti che sono la nostra benzina
neurochimica Va bene ok
due motori abbiamo in piedi quindi uno
che serve a lottare e sopravvivere
l'abbiamo ereditato in pieno l'altro è
più recente è un motore che potrebbe
costruire il futuro
salvare anche il senso delle nostre
comunità non è solo il fatto che le
comunità rimangano Ma che cosa deve
rimanere devono rimanere dei degli
energumeni che lottano per il territorio
per il denaro non so per il primato
Speriamo di no che non continui ad
essere la storia che vediamo quella che
è sotto i nostri occhi quindi processi
naturali da un lato che hanno prodotto
quelle cose e processi intellettivi
fanno le loro operazioni ma partono
dalle conoscenze che già posseggono
altrimenti devono fare una fatica
terribile Non lo so io per capire
qualcosa che oggi mi aiuta di più ad
aiutare le persone Ho dovuto fare un
viaggio pieno di angoscia dubbi diciamo
fatica e anche tanti errori
Ok queste due componenti tra quelle che
serve a lottare per sopravvivere e
quella che serve per costruire il futuro
sviluppare la propria vita dovrebbero
integrarsi abbiamo fatto questa immagine
adesso con l'aiuto di Edoardo abbiamo
trovato questa vedete che c'è un
dinamismo la freccia Celeste la freccia
quella che colore è un giallino non so
che cos'è crema ok dovrebbero integrarsi
dovrebbero come dire l'uno non
ostacolare l'altro noi possiamo vivere
anche con ansia e allarme Oggi stavo
spiegando al bar adesso dice come fa a
letto Antonino la sera dice quando le
luci si chiudono tutto buio Antonino va
a letto Ed è triste un po' sento triste
diciamo non lo so Io sono abituato
sopporto perché so quanti milioni di
persone
per non dire miliardi diciamo non
ricevono la parola e l'aiuto
l'accompagnamento diciamo a scoprire chi
sono si costruiscono delle idee di sé
che sono false perché solo quando le
idee sono false producono sofferenza
quando sono vere producono possono
produrre sofferenza ma la sofferenza che
un allievo di portare è un piccolo
miracolo questo che avviene per la
perfezione della natura dell'uomo ok
Quindi questa era l'integrazione
attenzione e qui a un certo punto Ecco
qua non è non è andata come nel tessuto
vedete sulla destra c'è un tessuto Ho
detto Aiutami Edoardo a far vedere come
trama E ordito devono intessersi diciamo
poi noi siamo in Italia che è un paese
straordinario vola una tradizione nei
tessuti non solo Italia pure penso
orientale le sete le cose per carità
però insomma noi ci abbiamo il Comasco
ci abbiamo comodo tutti le grandi
industrie ancora i grandi Marchi vanno
solo a Como Allora vedete potevano
essersi queste e invece
quasi sempre avviene il contrario
hai finito questo non c'è quella del
filmato non è apparsa
c'era il filmato in cui si muoveva la
cosa vabbè una è saltata Non fa niente
ve lo dico io ve lo dico ve lo faccio
immaginare con
la vostra fantasia con la vostra
immaginazione io volevo che il che la
parte Celeste quella antica quella
primitiva che deve lottare per vivere
faccio un esempio banale prendiamo
un'ansia un attacco di panico anche dite
quando il corpo modifica così le sue
sensazioni riceve una inclinazione come
dire spinge con un'inclinazione la mente
ad andare in allarme per cui la mente
cosa fa
Si oppone a quel fenomeno che ha
prodotto in Leva allarme e tenderebbe
con la sua azione intellettiva se non è
guidata è corretta da un processo
educativo
lanciarsi verso la parte Celeste del
corpo e quindi a sopprimere tutte le
persone che hanno tendenza ad ansie per
malattie o comunque per attacco di
panico vorrebbero che il corpo
diventasse silenzioso senza mandare più
un segnale
non accettano variazioni quindi
l'intelletto diventa intollerante e
deforma e tende ad opporsi e la parte
invece questa Celeste potente biologica
risponde male stavo spiegando questo
ieri a tavola degli amici gli ho detto
Ma gli risponde male il corpo gli dà
calci pugni e sputi sembra che io
esageri fa così a quel la persona che si
preoccupa con quei pensieri con quella
intenzionalità riceve una lezione che
non dimenticherà più però poi una
lezione Valletta ricostruita Allora
tornando a che serve tutto quello che vi
ho detto servirebbe a una sola cosa
dobbiamo creare scuole dove i ragazzi
vengano educati a capire come si
sviluppa così la loro azione Come si
sviluppa nei loro emozioni e i loro
sentimenti che cosa abbiamo con Cosa
Partiamo non è papà a mamma soltanto
poveretti tutti hanno difetti Però io mi
metto a dire inviderei a ringraziare di
qualsiasi piccola
azione detta tra le milioni delle azioni
che fanno i genitori per i figli ne
fanno migliaia migliaia migliaia a
settimana non non lungo il corso della
vita allora che voglio dire Poi è chiaro
che alcuni sbagli si fanno una volta mi
viene in mente in questo momento un
racconto che mi ha fatto una signora
eccezionale Una persona che questa ha
una testa che potrebbe guidare un mostro
un gigante di impresa intelligentissima
esperta uomo donna d'azienda però
esperta ha detto Ci stavamo andando in
viaggio verso verso
Perugia anzi
a un certo punto in spiaggia m'ha detto
dice ma proprio a me mi doveva capitare
di sentire una figlia che gli racconta
una cosa del genere gli ha raccontato
un'ansia del viaggio
era un po' di settimane che non si
sentiva più la stessa
Beh questa è una donna questa ragazza
che era fatto questo racconto che ha
avuto pena Cioè non è che s'è lanciata
non è che ha fatto tipo Antonino
Antonino è un bestia è un selvaggio
perché io ci metto la buona fede nelle
cose però se mi se mi tratti male io
ottica cancello o ti trattengo ti
delimito diciamo dai così diciamo che
sono abbastanza pronto a vedere che tu
quello che mi stai facendo
ma non tutti sono così sono persone
generosissime che finiscono col subire
col diventare persone che per proteggere
il padre che gli ha detto questo
si sono inchiodate si sono marmorizzate
si sono Nascoste dentro una statua che
non ha più espresso nulla
Io solo a parlarne mi sento
raggelare e il cuore allora dico
Facciamo scuole una volta ho parlato
nell' occasione della fondazione della
nostra università hanno delle per avere
i decreti attuativi costitutivi
istitutivi e poi attuativi dei corsi di
laurea detto ma possiamo fare un corso
ho detto possiamo fare una
sperimentazione nelle scuole dove
insegniamo
diciamo così alla conoscenza di sé una
materia sulla conoscenza di sé è una
materia anche sulla aiutare la
realizzazione personale e c'era una
persona un ministro
voglio precisare che è stata
gentilissima se onestamente ci ha
aiutato molto
e non me lo può dire questo non era il
protocollo dell'incontro deve rivolgersi
a un collaboratore va bene non se ne
fece niente all'epoca capisco che
un'impresa non facile però dobbiamo
provarci dobbiamo fare sperimentazione
per insegnare ai ragazzi chi sono Quali
sono le loro vere potenzialità e quando
scopriranno quei segnali lì di allarme
che verranno che vengono prodotti come
una fabbrica che è incessante
il corpo umano il cervello umano
fabbricano incessantemente segnali di
pericolo incessantemente segnali di
pericolo incessantemente segnare di
pericolo incessantemente sperano di
vedere qualcosa uno straccio un pezzo di
legno su cui sopravvivere in mezzo
all'acqua per paura di affogare non
stanno affogando
stanno vedendo cose che hanno visto le
generazioni precedenti addirittura le
specie precedenti che li hanno preceduti
È tutto diverso da come loro credono Ma
loro che devono pensare i ragazzi che si
accadendo Veramente in quel momento che
loro Anzi sono degli ansiosi sociali
sono degli non so hanno un disturbo
d'attacco panico hanno un Come si chiama
disturbo del comportamento alimentare
hanno dca hanno un CD e uno pseussi
compulsive disorder hanno una
depressione Maggiore hanno un disturbo
della personalità schizotipico uno dei
100-200 nomi di patologie non hanno
questo hanno anche questo è vero Io non
nego che ci sono ci sono ma da dove
partono partono da tendenze naturali che
non sono riconosciute e non essendo
riconosciute ricevono una risposta
non proprio la migliore e per cui si
loro non mollano quella parte Celeste
del cervello l'avete visto lì quella lì
quella non molla mai fino all'ultimo
attimo di vita fino all'ultimo istante
fa il suo dovere di mettere davanti a
l'opportunità oppure davanti a possibili
rischi perché quelli che sono
sopravvissuti sono quelli che sono
sopravvissuti con quelli che sono
allarmati non quelli sicuri i Sicuri
sono morti e noi siamo selezionati per
essere allarmabili bene io dico allora
spero un sogno il sogno di Antonino è
che nelle famiglie future Nelle coppie
future nelle vite dei ragazzi di tutte
le età negli uomini anziani di tutte le
età scoprono chi sono e Scoprono che i
modi anche di accompagnare questa loro
natura queste loro tendenze che non sono
cattive Ma sono quelle che sono hanno
quella vengono da lì dovevano fare quel
compito lo stanno facendo e per cui tu
devi solo sapere un po' meglio questo
per far funzionare il tuo apprendimento
a scuola quindi non avere ansia di
esaminazione Anzi del parlare in
pubblico non so non avere Anzi col
prossimo perché dovrei andare in ansia
col prossimo perché Eh ma la ragione
semplicissima vanno in ansia perché
senza accorgersi le persone a 12 13 14
anni e diventano dipendenti dagli
obiettivi che si sono dati rispetto al
loro gruppo rispetto ai loro coetanei se
io mi do degli obiettivi e questi
obiettivi salgono troppo Avete visto
quella quella diapositiva di prima
quando ho fatto vedere le minaccia un
attimo che un secondo eh ma tanto
esaltazione Eccolo delle opportunità di
salvezza io posso salvare me stesso
perché io piaccio io magari faccio
sorridere Io sono ricercato mi chiamano
mi vogliono sembra che quello sia la mia
salvezza la mia salvezza è solo sapere
chi sono
E da quello che sono così trovare
fare meno errori lungo il percorso che
mi porterà a compiere la mia vita Un
saluto a tutti
[Applauso]